Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Hélène VERNET
Bonsoir à tous.
J'ai commencé à m'intéresser
à la blockchain
le jour où j'ai compris que ce n'était pas
qu'une innovation technique,
mais le fondement d'un futur
Internet de la confiance.
J'en suis convaincu.
La blockchain sera,
aux services de confiance
comme les banques, les assurances
et même les avocats,
une révolution numérique
de l'ampleur de celle
que la Poste, les médias,
ou les services de l'information,
ont connue avec Internet.
Ce qui frappe, quand on s'intéresse
à la blockchain et à Internet,
c'est tout d'abord la similitude entre
les valeurs de leur communauté d'origine :
la protection de la vie privée,
la remise en cause des tiers de confiance,
le partage et la collaboration
entre les utilisateurs.
En 1996,
John Perry Barlow,
qui malheureusement
nous a quittés il y a deux mois,
a publié un texte fondateur
et historique sur Internet :
sa déclaration d'indépendance.
Dans ce texte,
il rejetait la souveraineté
de l'État sur ce nouveau territoire.
En 1994, à la même époque,
les crypto-anarchistes,
qui allaient devenir
la communauté d'adoption ou
de naissance de Bitcoin plus tard,
ont publié leur manifeste.
Dans celui-ci, ils affirment
que les gouvernements,
les sociétés commerciales
et les organisations sans visage,
ne nous accorderons pas une vie
privée par acte de bienveillance.
C'est un appel, resté sans réponse,
à régler ce problème par la technologie.
Et en effet,
Internet est devenu une zone
de pouvoir et une zone de surveillance.
Pas très loin de chez nous,
de l'autre côté de la Manche,
une entreprise anglaise,
Cambridge Analytica,
a manipulé les élections du Brexit
ainsi que les élections de la plus
puissante démocratie de la planète,
les États-Unis,
à l'aide de nos données Facebook.
À partir des liens
entre la blockchain et Internet,
plusieurs questions
me viennent à l'esprit.
La première, c'est :
est-ce que la blockchain va
suivre le même chemin qu'Internet ?
La deuxième, c'est :
est-ce que la marchandisation
et la concentration d'Internet
vont se retrouver sur la blockchain ?
La troisième, c'est :
est-ce que la blockchain va devenir
une zone de pouvoir et une zone
de surveillance comme Internet ?
Pour répondre à ces questions,
je vous propose de faire
un retour dans le passé,
et de regarder l'évolution d'Internet
par rapport à celle de la blockchain.
Pour Internet, tout commence
il y a cinquante ans,
quand l'armée américaine
met en place un réseau décentralisé,
capable donc de résister
à une attaque nucléaire,
afin de pouvoir communiquer.
Très rapidement, des geeks
un peu hippies, des libertaires,
comprennent que ce réseau
leur permettra de communiquer
les uns avec les autres
à l'abri de la censure
et de la propagande.
Je vous rappelle qu'à l'époque,
nous sommes en pleine guerre froide.
Pour ces pionniers,
Internet devait être le moyen
de concrétiser une liberté
d'expression totale.
Comme Internet,
Bitcoin, la première blockchain,
a été créé pour permettre
de s'échanger de la valeur
dans sa forme la plus simple : la monnaie,
pas comme PayPal,
mais de s'échanger de la monnaie
sans passer par un tiers de confiance,
une banque ou l'État.
Bitcoin a été créé en 2008,
et ce n'est pas un hasard.
2008, c'est la date
de l'une des plus grandes
trahisons des tiers de confiance :
la crise des subprimes.
Pendant des années,
les banques nous ont assuré
que la situation était sous contrôle,
que tout allait bien.
Elles ont pourtant provoqué
une crise mondiale
qui a plongé dans la misère
des millions de gens,
et mis même des États à genoux.
Et ce sont nos impôts, à nous
les citoyens, qui ont sauvé la finance.
Face à cette trahison,
la blockchain ne propose pas
une réponse juridique
ou une réponse politique,
elle propose une réponse technologique,
celle de payer, de gérer
de la richesse entre nous,
sur un réseau qui soit collectif,
sans passer par les banques,
justement, ou les États.
La blockchain est avant tout un idéal,
un idéal où chaque individu
serait totalement libre de gérer
sa richesse numérique
et totalement responsable.
La blockchain, c'est la promesse
d'une indépendance financière,
comme Internet a été la promesse
d'une liberté d'expression absolue.
Pourtant Internet n'a pas
tenu sa promesse.
Alors que s'est-il passé ?
À quel moment l'histoire
d'Internet a-t-elle basculé ?
On le sait aujourd'hui.
Dans les années 1990,
certaines sociétés ont compris
le phénomène de numérisation
du monde qu'accompagnait Internet.
Amazon est né en 1994.
À l'époque, il vendait des livres.
Google est né dans un garage en 1998.
Évidemment, en ce temps-là,
personne ne les a pris au sérieux.
Nous, en France, on continuait
à utiliser le Minitel,
et le gouvernement français
recevait alors un rapport
du nom de son auteur M. Théry,
qui affirmait qu'Internet,
dont le chiffre d'affaires mondial
ne correspond même pas
au douzième de celui du Minitel,
n'était sûrement pas un bon moyen de
faire des services commerciaux en ligne.
On a, encore une fois,
été des précurseurs !
Pendant ce temps-là,
Amazon, Google, et Facebook,
ont, eux, très bien compris
les nouvelles règles du jeu :
proposer des services sans limite
à l'échelle de ce réseau mondial,
et des services le plus souvent gratuits
car fonctionnant sur la collecte
de nos données personnelles.
La conséquence est connue :
ces services sont devenus
des points de passage obligés,
et les chiffres aujourd'hui
sont effrayants.
Quatre-vingt quinze pourcent,
ce sont les recherches sur Internet
que vous faites à l'aide d'un seul
moteur de recherche : Google.
Soixante-quinze pourcent,
ce sont les revenus
de la publicité en ligne
qui tombent dans l'escarcelle
de Facebook et Google.
2020, c'est la date à laquelle on estime
que les chiffres d'affaires
cumulés des GAFA -
Google, Amazon, Facebook et Apple -
en feront la première puissance
économique mondiale.
La blockchain, elle aussi, se marchandise.
Il est loin, désormais, le temps
où les pionniers du Bitcoin
étaient de doux anarchistes libertaires.
Ils sont devenus, maintenant,
soit millionnaires,
soit des chefs d'entreprises florissantes.
Et surtout, ils ont tourné
le dos à leurs idéaux.
Finie la décentralisation,
désormais, ils veulent créer
des entreprises centralisées.
C'est tout le paradoxe :
un réseau libre, ouvert et décentralisé
peut accueillir des services qui eux
sont centralisés et concentrés.
C'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement avec Internet.
Vous auriez pu, au lieu de faire
vos recherches sur Google,
taper directement le nom du site
dans la barre de recherche,
mais nous passons tous par Google.
Google collecte nos données,
nous propose un meilleur service,
et la boucle est bouclée.
Aujourd'hui, Google est devenu
la seule porte d'entrée dans le web.
Et c'est un problème.
Le même phénomène, aujourd'hui,
se reproduit dans la blockchain.
Quand j'ai acheté mon premier Bitcoin -
mon premier morceau de Bitcoin -
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un,
je lui ai donné de l'argent,
il m'a donné du Bitcoin,
ça s'est fait entre nous,
sans tiers de confiance.
Désormais, je passe
par une plateforme centralisée.
Aux États-Unis, Coinbase,
la principale plate-forme d'achat
et de vente de Bitcoins au monde,
compte plus de 15 millions d'utilisateurs.
C'est dix fois plus qu'il y a deux ans.
Cette croissance exponentielle
me fait penser que Coinbase va bientôt
devenir le Google du Bitcoin,
c'est-à-dire l'unique porte d'accès.
À quoi bon avoir un réseau décentralisé
et libre, s'il n'y a qu'une seule porte ?
Surtout qu'évidemment cette concentration
n'est pas compatible avec les valeurs
d'origine de la communauté blockchain.
Les services qui étaient ouverts
aujourd'hui sont fermés.
Le partage et la collaboration
ont laissé la place
à la concurrence et à la consommation.
Pire,
la protection de la vie privée
et la confidentialité
ont laissé place à l'identification
systématique et à la collecte de données.
Coinbase, toujours lui,
a récemment été obligé
de transmettre plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'identités au fisc américain.
Alors la question fiscale m'intéresse
particulièrement en tant qu'avocat -
vous pouvez vous rasseoir,
je ne vais pas vous parler de fiscalité -
parce qu'elle nous permet
d'aborder la dernière pierre
à l'édifice de la centralisation.
C'est la réglementation.
La réglementation part toujours
d'un bon sentiment :
protéger les consommateurs,
vous protéger,
et me faire travailler.
Mais la réglementation,
c'est-à-dire désagrément,
c'est également une barrière
entre ceux qui en profitent -
ceux qui sont agréés -
et ceux qui ne le sont pas.
Et cette barrière est d'autant
plus difficile à franchir
quand un agrément peut coûter
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros.
Alors où est-ce que cette marchandisation
de la blockchain nous mène ?
Elle nous mène à une situation ironique.
Les services blockchain,
nés après la crise de 2008,
vont devenir ce qu'ils ont toujours
dénoncé : des banques.
Oui, tout simplement des banques !
Alors évidemment,
nous sommes passés de l'utopie
à la marchandisation,
de la marchandisation à la concentration.
Et la concentration, c'est une notion
qui a à voir avec le pouvoir.
Ces services, aujourd'hui,
n'ont-ils pas trop de pouvoir ?
Sur Internet, les jeux sont faits.
Les plateformes numériques, les GAFA,
ont, aujourd'hui, un pouvoir économique
qui leur permet de tuer l'innovation
dont ils ont pourtant tant profité.
Face à une idée nouvelle ou un concurrent,
que fait un GAFA ?
Il vous propose deux choix :
je te rachète -
c'est ce que Facebook a fait
avec Instagram en 2015
pour un milliard de dollars -
ou alors je te laisse
accéder à ma plateforme,
mais sous mes conditions,
sous mon contrôle.
Et aujourd'hui, qui peut lancer
un service quel qu'il soit,
sans passer par Google,
Facebook, YouTube, ou Apple ?
Personne.
Certains ont essayé.
Ils ont évidemment eu un problème.
Protonmail est un service mail
qui se caractérise par un très
grand respect de la vie privée.
Il se pose comme une alternative à Gmail.
En 2015, Google - donc Gmail -
l'a tout simplement retiré
des résultats de recherche,
non pas pendant quelques heures
ou quelques jours, mais pendant dix mois.
C'est-à-dire que pendant dix mois,
un service numérique a disparu d'Internet,
service qui évidemment a presque
failli mettre la clé sous la porte.
Au final, face à ces plateformes,
c'est : « Je t'achète ou je te soumets »,
ou comme dirait Pablo Escobar :
« Prends mon or ou prends mon plomb. »
C'est un pouvoir économique donc,
mais également un pouvoir sociétal.
Comme l'a révélé Edward Snowden en 2013,
la formidable machine de surveillance
devenue folle des États-Unis
n'espionnait pas seulement
les ennemis de l'Amérique,
mais également des
gouvernements - la France -
des chefs d'État - Angela Merkel -
ou de simples citoyens -
peut-être certains d'entre vous.
Ce qui me choque dans cette affaire,
ce n'est pas qu'un gouvernement
ou qu'un service de renseignements
nous surveille et nous
mente - ça, on a l'habitude ! -
mais plutôt qu'ils se sont appuyés sur des
collaborateurs pour le moins inattendus :
c'est l'entreprise numérique
chantre de la transparence,
de l'horizontalité et de la bienveillance.
« Don't be evil ! » nous dit Google.
La blockchain connaîtra
bientôt ses géants,
et rien ne permet de croire
que la blockchain sera
à l'abri des dérives d'Internet.
Au fur et à mesure que la puissance
des entreprises blockchain grandira,
comment être sûr qu'elle
n'utilisera pas son pouvoir
pour tuer l'innovation,
écarter ses concurrents,
et pour maximiser ses profits ?
Au fur et à mesure que leur
puissance économique augmentera,
comment être sûr qu'elles
pourront résister longtemps
à la pression des gouvernements
qui leur demanderont de nous surveiller
au nom, par exemple, de la lutte
contre le terrorisme ?
Avec un détail près :
la blockchain est fondée -
je ne rentre pas dans les détails -
sur un registre qui
est transparent et ouvert.
Sachez juste que c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour notre vie privée.
Au fur et à mesure que la blockchain
entrera dans nos vies,
comme Internet est entré
dans nos vies avant elle,
les limites au contrôle et à la
surveillance des tiers de confiance
seront de plus en plus difficiles à fixer.
Vous l'avez compris,
je ne suis pas très optimiste
sur l'évolution de la blockchain.
Elle ne supprimera pas les tiers
de confiance, elle en créera de nouveaux.
Alors que faire ?
Quand tout va mal,
il faut relire Churchill.
Il a dit à son peuple :
« Si vous oubliez votre passé,
vous serez condamné à le revivre. »
Alors j'aimerais vous dire,
à vous qui êtes là, ce soir,
également à tout le peuple du numérique :
apprenons de notre négligence coupable
avec les géants du numérique.
Aux utilisateurs d'abord,
j'aimerais leur dire :
pendant des années,
nous n'avons pas prêté suffisamment
attention à la concentration des pouvoirs
dans les mains de
quelques géants sur Internet.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons
une seconde chance.
La révolution blockchain
est, en effet, au stade d'Internet
dans les années 1990.
Tout reste à faire.
Donc, ouvrez grand les yeux,
et surtout adoptez un esprit critique
et politique sur la technologie.
C'est à ce prix
que la blockchain pourra faire
d'Internet un Internet de la confiance.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)